jared your character transformations are
truly incredible would you consider your
role as paolo gucci the most
unrecognizable yet
i don't know it's a good question and uh
for me i
i absolutely fell in love with the
character he's a guy who's you know he's
a dreamer he's bigger than life he's uh
he's uh
he's full of humor and um
you know
it's a guy who really wanted to make
something special with his life and to
share it with the world and never had
that opportunity so he's very frustrated
but he's still fighting uh to be heard
to be seen and
to share his his designs with the world
so for me it was absolute dream
to bring the character to life
oh i love that are there any parts of
any characters that you've played that
have stayed with you in real life after
the fact
yeah i think you learn a lot from every
experience that you have and you bring a
little piece of the characters with you
or some kind of insight
about humanity about character about
family about circumstances
and you know paulo was a real love
affair for me and
you know it's sad to see him go
yeah i heard you cried on the well you
almost cried you almost cried on the
last day of set you were so emotional
that it was over
yeah these these cold
dead eyes almost shed a tear
you know it was very emotional i think
that the ire said i think we all fell in
love with paulo you know he's a guy who
wears his heart in his sleeve of course
he's a hot mess
but uh you know he's uh he's one of a
kind
yes truly um gaga said that she kept her
accent for nine months after filming
does that sort of thing happen to you
how long does it take for you to get
back to your authentic self
well it depends i mean you know if you
do a lot of work even making a physical
commitment to something uh either weight
loss or gain or the way you change the
way you talk it can take a little bit
to get rid of it because it's become a
habit
um and of course it's no secret that i i
i
i love immersive
acting and i love transformation and
those are things that i'm passionate
about and
i've been working that way my pretty
much my entire career and
it's uh it's quite you know an uh an
organic and normal thing and it's not
such a bad thing if it takes a little
while for
the character to kind of uh
you know uh leave
but uh i think that means you're
probably just doing the right thing um
yeah you're also a fashion icon first
solo mail to appear on vogue greece i
saw you walking in the gucci love parade
by the way in hollywood really good job
were there any pieces on set that you
wanted to take when shooting this film i
think i kept the purple suit uh the
i just had to and uh i do like to keep
an outfit from all my characters that it
plays just a little memento
um but uh
you know this every outfit in this film
is incredible on every character
and i think a lot of people are going to
be shocked by this film because we all
know gucci we all know the brand we all
know that name that legendary name
but i don't think very many people know
about this story about this this this
crazy dynasty this family the story of
betrayal and power and murder
uh so i i'm excited for audiences to
come out to theaters and i think it'll
probably be the maybe the one of the
first movies that people see post covid
uh and uh you know i think people are
really gonna enjoy it
that's awesome thank you for your time
jared great work as always
you